when you see a patent that's concrete
you try and express that time in odd
strands
okay great so this here whatever that's
right is the binomial theorem this is
the theorem of explaining all of these
guys these we defined at the very
beginning as coefficients of this right
and then somehow the rabbit-hole took a
stall this factorial business right now
you see the point of Wednesday's lesson
okay let's begin this easy bits first
it's a fraction it's a fraction what's
on the top any factorial every single
time that's your building block that's
where you always stop on the denominator
I always seem to have two factorials
right so you factors that go together
one of them is fixing up this one and
there's another which is actually
dividing right so I noticed some things
that are very you know structured about
the phenomena
besides the two factorials what do they
always add up to they always add up to 6
or should I say n right so one of them
is this number can you see that look at
this let's all look at 6 to see four
right 64 the 4 factorial is right there
see it
63 the free factorial is there etc right
so one of these factorials will be our
factorial now if I want these two to add
together to be n it's gonna be n minus R
factorial BAM that that is the binomial
theorem
okay now what's beautiful about this is
really my pose all these questions to
you about Pascal's triangle I'm like why
why why why why well when you get to
something like this it's not a new thing
to memorize its watch how this makes
sense of everything okay exhibit and
see zebra what is NC 0 according to this
definition is n factorial on 0 factorial
+ - 0 factorial right which is n
factorial on 1 times n factorial which
better be 1
let's try the other one we said that n
see and write what was that equal to
let's just go to the definition it's in
factorial on tummy and n factorial and
minus n factorial it is n factorial an N
factorial 0 factorial which is 1 let me
give you another one we said this old
triangle is symmetrical and then we went
to the effort of expressing that
symmetry in terms all that NCR notation
right I believe we said something like
this didn't we right if you look at it
from one side it's gonna be equal to the
same time on the same road from the
other side right well it's hella good
look at it let's just quickly prove this
my hand side ok I won't need much work
that's N and - ah ok by definition a
definition
watch out me tell me the easy bit what's
on the numerator
what's on the denominator I'm gonna have
this factorial and then I'm going to
have to watch I've got a lot of
different letters flying around and
sometimes being reused which is a bit
tricky
it's gonna be end - that guy said you
know by coincidence okay
what's an equal true that's n factorial
on and - ah factual n- n- - negative uh